وانتهى مشهد اخر من القتل ومن الدمار ومن
التضحيات مشهد من سيره الحرب على قطاع غزه
من سيره النكبه التي كانت ولم تزل هل
تختلف مشاهد القصف بين حرب وحرب الا
بمقدار الاختلاف بين قتل وقتل ويؤمن
الا تتشابه مواكب الشهداء بين امس واليوم
الشهداء الذين يمنحون للموت معنى الحياه
وللقضيه الفلسطينيه معنى ان تبقى حيه قضيه
تقلق الضمير الانساني وان تعامى عنها ليس
بوصفها ذكرى لنكبه حدثت عام 48
غضبت بتواطؤ دولي ان تلقي شعبا من الوجود
وان تبعث اخر
الاعتداء الاسرائيلي الاخير على غزه الذي
اغتال عددا من القاده في سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي ودمر وقتل
واصاب بنا المدنيين ما اصاب هو فصل من
تاريخ متصل على مدى خمسه وسبعين عاما منذ
كانت الاصابات تقتل وتحرق وتستبيح البدن
والبلدات الفلسطينيه لتصنع دولتها على
حساب الفلسطيني وتصنع مشروع امنها وحياتها
على ارهاب الفلسطيني ودفعه الى اللجوء
والنزوح قصه النكبه امس هي قصتها اليوم
ومعادله امس هي معادلتها اليوم سلام
اسرائيل وتوسعها مرتبط ارتباط عضويا بقتل
فلسطيني وارحابه وسجنه ودفعه الى حواف
العدم باقتلاعه من الارض
خمسه ايام غزه الاخيره ليست مقطعه عن
تاريخ النكبه انها شاهد على استمرارها في
جميع الجغرافيا الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وفي القدس في غزه على نحو اخص تاخذ
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه معنى مختلفا فهي
استهداف لاخر القلاع التي لم يخدرها وهم
السلام
تعود ذكرى النكبه بعد 75 عاما وعمليه
السلام المفض الى الدوله الفلسطينيه لا
يكاد يذكرها احد انها قضيه منسيه لا تذكر
بها الا المواجهات التي تجد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مدفوعه اليها دفاعا عن النفس
وعن القدس ومقدساتها وقد اصطنع العالم
بكثير من المكر مصطلحي التهدئه والتصعيد
لاداره الصراع الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي وذلك
بافراغه من محتواه السياسي ومن قضيته
الاساسيه وهي الصراع على الارض بين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبين الشعب الفلسطيني
المطالب بحقوقه المدافع عنها ومصطلح
التهدئه يعني اي يكف الطرفان الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني عن المواجهه عن العنف
ويخلد الى الهدوء الهدوء الذي لا تبدد
سكينته طلقه ماء او مظاهره ما ضد تدريس
المسجد الاقصى او مص ارض او هدم منزل
التهدئه تعني تابيد الوضع على ما هو عليه
تابيد الاحتلال اما التصعيد فهو خروج على
الوضع الراهن تجب مسارعه لاحتوائه
واحتوائه يعني اسكات المقاومه بين يدي
ذكرى النكبه القديمه الجديده لا حديث عن
عمليه السلام لا حديث عن دعوه الاطراف
للجلوس الى طاوله التفاوض فالحديث عن
الشرعيه الدوليه وعن حق الشعوب في تحرير
ارضها وحقها في المقاومه لا يزعفه السياق
هنا ففلسطين ليست اوكرانيا التي يمجد
الغرب شجاعتها في حرب الغاصبين ارضها
الاعتداء الاخير على غزه متزامنا مع
ذكريات النكبه الاولى يدعو الفلسطيني سجين
مصطلحي تهدئه والتصعيد وهما مصطلحان
يكرسان الاحتلال كما لا يفعل اي مصطلح اخر
انهما مصطلحان يكرسان النكبه الفلسطي ليس
باعتبارها ماساه فلسطينيه وقعت في الماضي
بل يحرسان صيرورتها
الماساويه اليوم وغدا وسيبقى يان كذلك حتى
ترد القضيه الى اصلها صراع بين قوه
اسرائيليه معتديه غاصبه للارض وبين شعب
يقاتل من اجل حقوقه خارج مصطلحي التهدئه
والتصعيد اللذين يؤننان المعتديه ويسكتان
الضحيه وهذه مقاربه في راي كثير من
الفلسطينيين اقل ما تفعله انها تؤبد
الاحتلال
تؤبد النكبه